blähungen ist der in der medizin
gebräuchliche fachausdruck für die
normale gasansammlung im damen die auf
grund der verdauungs vorgänge im
verdauungstrakt von höheren vielzähligen
tieren einschließlich des menschen
entsteht und dabei das wohl organ darm
aufbläht meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen hier heute zum volk simulator
2008 7
ein schild da hinten erhält dadurch eine
komplett neue bedeutung diese gelbe
figur hier sind wir und wir müssen
einfach ein bisschen rumlaufen und
können dann beispielsweise einfach den
typen antworten und ich hab verloren
solche menschen sind normale menschen
die kann nicht einfach antwort sie haben
jetzt zum beispiel auch zwei auf einmal
an und kurz hier die vorne kann ich an
kurzen die kann ich an kurzen der typ
hier heißt love a double fahrt mal
wieder dass hier unten ist allerdings
ein polizist und der darf mich nicht
kriegen und daher friedliche vorne jetzt
mal an dann wird sich noch mal den warum
bin ich danach weil mein vater immer
abgelaufen ist so komplex also ich muss
wirklich die ganze zeit leute ans putzen
also hier beispielsweise dann kurz jetzt
im jahr an dann gehe ich jetzt wieder
hier runter und fuhr zuletzt wieder an
dann gehe ich hier hoch und gucken ob
ich ihnen noch kriege ich ihnen auch und
warum werde ich zu einem stück scheiße
wenn ich sterbe ich muss hier auf jeden
fall auf 30.000 punkte kommen damit ich
den nächsten den nächsten game mode oder
irgendwie so keine ahnung wie das hier
genau haid freischalten
das heißt ich jetzt mal hier runter
vorzusehen ja kann ich denke ich kann
mir weglaufen kann ich ja auch an kurz
nach oben
man muss auf so viele sachen
gleichzeitig aufpassen wenn ich
einerseits auf den vorteil war also das
man halt genug leute an wurde in der
zeit und dann bekomme ich immer was
drauf also wenn ich jetzt spur zu sehen
die schon der vater geht hoch das heißt
ja für auch nicht unfassbar viel zeit ab
sofort muss 2000 das hier sind diese
muskelprotz sie darf nicht an kurzen sie
hier kann ich anfangen wo jetzt noch
einmal ok ok 40 ankommen hey double
fahrt ok sehr stark
[Musik]
ich habe neun boost fuhr zwei polizisten
auf einmal arbeit double fahrt ok krass
okay hier geht es weiter dann geh ich
aktion zudem ihr einer fahrt der mag das
ganze anscheinend sogar hier freunde
viertes projekt da wo meine kämen gerade
vor es habe ich auch noch drei leben die
daran gezeigt werden als ist anscheinend
auch so dass ich irgendwie leben habe
und irgendwie mir fehler erlauben kann
dementsprechend aber ich weiß nicht
genau wie das dann aussehen soll
ich werde jetzt aber auf jeden fall
erstmal die polizei am 14 und noch mal
eben die muss ich jedoch ich habe euch
heute mal wieder auf instagram gefragt
aber was ich heute hochladen soll ob ich
entweder ebay fails hochladen soll oder
dieses video hier wo ich es konnte die
polizei jetzt habe ich eine
ausgeschaltete jetzt geht der polizist
zur seite aber ich weiß nicht warum
danke dir alles alles klar als tag habe
ich auf jeden fall heute mal wieder auf
instagram gefragt ob ich ebay fels
hochladen soll oder ob ich diesen
forcierter hochladen sondern das meinten
tatsächlich mehr leute dass ich den vor
zehn monate hochladen und das hat mich
schon sehr gewundert falls ihr das
nächste mal auf jeden fall auch
mitentscheiden wollt was sich hochladen
sondern auf einem kanal also
beispielsweise morgen direkt schon das
könnte mir jetzt auf instagram folgen
laser laser lukas ist kostenlos sie mir
da folgt und ich lade auch echt versuche
mehr video bilder hochzuladen
ich strenge mich gerade heftig an zu
putzen und in cortina die polizei ich
weiß nicht ob ich wirklich zu blöd bin
für einen furz simulator aber ich will
also ich weiss ich kleidung vielleicht
habt ihr das game ja schon mal gesagt
das gibt es auf jeden fall bei steam für
79 cent
da weiß man schon was das für ein spiel
sein sollte und die polizei verfolgt
mich schon wieder das heißt hier sagt
double triple fahrzeuge plus 2000 ja
nochmal den polizisten weg ich habe nur
noch zwei leben steht da aber jetzt
könnt ihr wieder ganz gut zusammen
ich bin busted
13.500 punkte wie soll ich denn auf
30.000 kommen
busted wurz durch dahl 1 1 zu recht
wurde an der stelle das heute wieder zu
beenden meine lieben freunde erst auf
instagram abgestimmte meinte hey jude
heute bitte nicht übel fällt so laden
sondern den vater und ich kann die
entscheidung nicht nachvollziehen
oder ich bin abgrundtief chance in
diesem spiel wenn euch das video
allerdings seien auch gefallen da würde
ich mich selber einen daumen hoch unter
dem video hier von euch freuen schreibt
mir gerne und in die kommentare was sich
morgen für ein video hochladen soll oder
volkmann auf instagram denn dort könnt
ihr mir die hände schreiben oder ich
mache oft mal abstimmungen und dann
dürft ihr quasi entscheiden was sie
hochladen soll abonniert dazu auch gerne
einen kanal hier auf youtube damit ihr
das video dann nicht verpasst und sonst
kommt jetzt auch tatsächlich dann das
auto
[Musik]